hey guys chastity and Mary here and
we're about to jump into some butt
sniffing pugs action so but seven pugs
is kind of an exploratory fun game where
you're playing some dogs and you're just
exploring central bark it's everything
you've ever wanted from a game and I saw
this a lot at trade show like at various
shows like a pax if you might have even
heard of it or seen other people
covering it but I never had a chance to
play it me neither this is my first time
impression with butt sniffing pugs he
looks so cute yeah so I thought we'd
give the demo as tries do it let's give
them the mole or I well I think we're
picking our pugs so um I will let's see
oh my gosh they're all so cute I'm gonna
pick the one that looks like my puppy
see mom I assume I have no idea how the
controls work because I had just started
0 x there we go that seems reasonable
all right so I'm gonna be this guy four
of them I'm gonna choose this little
derpy boy he's eddying um and then it's
so choose hopefully it works yes and
then why to start here we go okay but
sniffed change power all right let's but
stands let's come to my I believe it's
why to sniff booty oh let me smell your
come here yeah all right and then I
think your powers are anything from X to
eat that's adorable some excellent art
thing it could be be then okay why I'm
panting be up there we go take my be be
to take a pee bark to bet beckon p to
repel all right so let's let's try out
some systems here video games Oh check
mark I just get a trophy for nothing can
I Shyheim duckies I'll do with me what
do you do with a trophy it just exists
in the world facing you all right but
the fountain okay
right hi there my name's moose I'm the
main Great Dane here in central bark
nice although personally I'd like to
consider myself more of an okay day he's
so modest I news as good as mine again I
think we both knew sorry how do you play
this game you say yeah how do you play
this game solve puzzles catch some
wildlife deck out your doghouse but
sniffing pugs is about having fun silly
oh shut up and you don't mind me I'll
just float while you play and give you
tips if I see anything cool have fun
he's our guide dog that's cool seems
like a great dane to me he does I love
that solve puzzles with powers alright
so I think a lot of this is just kind of
exploratory let's go check out more of
central bars your eyes there's no good
way when we like get back to it just
clean it looks so good we just
appreciate for a hot second how dirty
little business admitting another
business axolotls all on land kill those
ants and get those axolotls to the pond
alright so where are the oh there they
okay yeah alright so maybe pee on them
let's use our p power is let's see
oh oops I poop shoot we need to switch
powers maybe let me sniff your butt my
butt there we go all right let's see if
that works work that yes all right
they're gone good job I think we do that
on task feel pretty good about that I
don't do with these pigeons I'd be
barking at him I guess we're just being
dogs what would dogs do in these
situations boys run around I go to the
park with my pepper weekly and I'll tell
you right now he does not solve puzzle
he tries to smell as many bus as
possible on bones oh we can buy stuff
alright so you can deck out your I
wonder if we split the bones or if those
are your buddy over my head let me check
out and see if you both benefit from
this and what if you stiffed my butt I
just that's the solution everything I
assume it yeah I'm go back oh I gotta
dig power now let me see what I do I
pooped again sniffing and then just okay
all right not a net oh I can catch bugs
yeah I want to catch food you're gettin
it on all man yes scoot is my new power
the but scale of the blood scoot in love
windows do you do was really hate when
they're dead but after gonna cross there
Cartman I don't know how that happened I
think it used why or just walked over it
several times it could be you got an egg
chair you can place that in other
furniture in your tree house oh great we
have a tree house yeah I think that's
like our little pug domain hearing some
bugs hopefully I'm just wiping my ass
across these flowers try walking over
the net
just try mashing different button
combinations oh where why to enter
furniture everything hey gave us
everything I wanted I just want to get
uh okay player one press Y to exit
furniture mode I enjoy furniture man he
just gets them I thought we did but
maybe you have to do it oh it's not
letting me ok it's only me that's really
weird only only player 1 can do it ok I
want to put something down we get
something that's just a trace oh there
we go oh there we go yeah there's our
share all right I'd like share place
that down yay we have a chair in our
tree house oh I can do multiple chairs
there's one for each of our pugs sure ok
and then why to exit furniture would I
love my faceless little Tibo hole they
really thought of everything sniff you
in here yeah I guess this is more of
like a all right should we exit
furniture moves yeah sure its egg chair
egg chairs now this is just a demo
there's definitely more to be done in
this game I think they're kind of just
showing you the capabilities what could
be what could be in this game I wish we
had the butt sniffing controller that
they had some of those trade shows that
i saw this i saw that those looked
really cute always peppers I know that
dog you do yeah i think that dog is
based off of pepper Scoville max ghazals
doll I know I'm talking about there's
famous dogs all over here I think they
honestly need to add my puppy they
should they should add little C Mon it's
nice to see my old roommate peppers here
oh my gosh is a new no selling bread
right now let's find out so if we buy
some bread i bet you we could feed it to
the duckies but wait i don't know how
many bones we have do you have the
do I have the boat so we used to have 50
bones but i think we bought a net with
it so we might be out of bones what kind
of fireflies nice i think you can also
catch this snail on their ladybug and
that's given you some hot bones I really
want to sniff peppers is what I caught a
common butterfly I've seen a lot of
those around lately yeah I don't like we
have enough money yet oh he's peeing but
we're getting there so they set golden
bug I want that come here bug I mean
give me I'm trying to catch this bug
this is me is easy dad you know I'm just
trying to talk to him and he keeps
barking at me and I always thought about
that kind of stuff in the dog world you
know some dogs have to be dicks yeah
it's a good point like I just made fun
of me for catching a snail so how do we
buy oh I got some bread nice pick out
patterns I'm sure the baby ducks would
love that all right let's do it go to
the pigeons head baby ducks and I catch
you guys like bread oh here they are
here some baby duckies I'm gonna try to
put them in this nut how do I get the
bread for them hey guys I've got some
bread I just don't know how to get it to
you
so it says bite and dig it doesn't say
anything else let me let me kind of oh
yeah it's try sipping my butt and see if
to get different powers um chic flowers
nice oh that's gonna look great in our
treehouse I love that they're chic I'm
so shaved considered everything sorry I
let me give me my but 50 bones oh oh is
that just rode image I don't know what I
did all I did was right there are some
things there's a bug on your crotch
there ok let's go I'd like to put the
vows in as well bazan all right hey I'd
like to life except the place yeah
really really how beautiful let me see
so that's all we have right ok I'd
really like to see more options here if
I like this doesn't really look like a
dog house to me no I would like to put a
bunch of like bone shaped furniture no
yeah I want way more options nice big
bed all right let's go back you can see
the possibilities yes here's a lot of
possible cuz again like this is just a
demo like this isn't this isn't fully
realized yet it's pretty cute though god
it's cute and I love the music so let's
see what else is there to do besides pee
and poop I do what those are things we
shouldn't know we're just being
ourselves risk being puppies I swear the
next thing should be to give the bread
to the duck I just don't know how yet
yes we got a dreamy 10 okay did you get
that cuz you you went to us I went on
the slide come down the slide with me
yes Oh scoot Galloway scoot I'm peeing
on this frog checking out I found a
bubble wand all right whoa did you made
that frog blow up I think now he's like
a balloon guy you sleep I'm like still
trying to figure out how to pick up crap
but i'll tell you right now I'm I
sniffed to it's so cute I just tried to
set up pepper is inelia and he wasn't
having it nothing now that peppers
doesn't hate us anymore maybe we can do
gonna catch the duck raag with my nut
you got the net I got on it so there's a
bug over here by this hole that I bet
you could catch oh yeah probably and
there's another seasick bugs everywhere
yeah I caught a pill bow nice haha he
keeps making jokes their jokes terrible
driving with the dead jokes come here
little ducks we have bread I just don't
know where the bread went but I
definitely bought you bread I'm gonna
pee on this dog cuz he was rude to us
for so long and I'm gonna pee on his
pizza that's pooping and butts cushy
cute and poop
those are important do I fertilize these
flowers is what what's the you do yeah
Oh making my garden grow pooping
everywhere open straight up pooping
everywhere god that's funny like this Oh
scoot just making little poop trails
everywhere I go look how happy it makes
me it makes flowers when I scoot no look
I'm scooting and making far just like
real dog yes yeah you're creating a
garden I'm making the greatest garden an
ass garden yes with my butt oh no I are
my butt flowers disappearing I guess
there's not permanent yeah I'm amazed
they make flowers at all to be honest
with you it's true does it seem like
that should be the case but here we are
come on there has to be where's the
bread it's in our docket I believe I
just don't know how we deliver said
bread hey guys can I buy something else
I can use everything says sold in the
lowes so I feel like we've done it why
are you working you're off the clock
guys jazzy I'm hang out let me sniff
your butt I want to find out what you're
about i bet you it's just new skills and
trying them out in the ipod so let me
sniff your butt again and try out a
different skill cool so now i have
barking and digging maybe I'll bark at
some frogs digging is how you found that
one thing right I think so you could try
sniffing my butt and seeing if you can
get a different skill fightin Zig or
have bite and dig in the right you just
never know when these things are gonna
come in handy what am I gonna bite see
like can I do this hole in the ground
you'd think that that would mean dig
here
I tried to buy I base that off of for
nothing think like a pug things like a
pug trying to eat flowers in your mouth
spread you have a bread oh I had to use
fight oh the hens are trying to steal it
do it for them fight them I got the
bread I left to go go go go go duckies
barking i'm working at them we did it
excellent we've done it floating we got
a duck floaty yeah we got a duck Flynn
let all the Ducks are following me in
you Oh got the bread so I just left I'm
gonna lure them into this hole Oh No
follow me ducklings that's so cute i
love that they're still with us should
we send our duck floaty looks like or
we're Camille I think this is it I mean
I don't know let's we'll put our duck
floaty up okay and then we'll see if we
can we'll see if there's anything else
to do but I think this is a quick demo
just to show you the possibilities oh
what's that that's our tense tense our
fancy little tent and then up there's
the duck floating no yeah just as we
wanted looks cool yeah we got a lot of
stuff going on for us here we've done
we've done quite well sweet our
treehouse of fun but
I leave something to be desired like I'd
like to sleep in here yeah I liked and
I'd like to nap sit in my egg chair me
too haha bike you down would you go and
I go I'm gone how did that happen where
help me i'm in the upside oh wait I
found me every appeared was is that a
bug yeah I think it might be okay looks
again out this is a demo so yep oh oh
that you are I was just like off-screen
okay all right is there anywhere else to
go i think they tried to get back here
but i think this is the one in room your
lace what do you think about it I think
it's cute see the potential yes there's
some potential for some fun hug fun
anywhere I don't know can I see if
you're about one or two sure thang yes 0
King on these little duckling just
peeing on everything this is definitely
a cute game I like that there's some
pugs here and you're sniffing butts and
I think you can definitely see the
potential and I some different powers oh
here this is a digging hole can you um
yeah if you don't have that power sniff
yeah okay so dig yeah what is that so
you can make holes here and I think
eventually they'll be like more stuff to
uncover in all this area I think it's
just gonna be like a cute little puzzle
adventure game that you get to solve
with each other that's cute yeah it's a
fun little co-op experience for you and
your buddies open what else can i bite
burning out of bites there's bugs you
can grab it's gonna buy this [ __ ] in
that hole see how that a good plan what
happens did anything happen what if I
dig it up take it dig up my poop oh and
it went down the hall you didn't think
that that would work but here we are
there it is oh that's so cute that's
pretty much it that's pretty much it I
hope you guys liked this I mean it's a
cute little thing you can kind of see
where it's going and I guess we'll just
see the possibilities you know with this
game cuz it's currently on Kickstarter
yes currently on Kickstarter and then
it's coming to ps4 and PC Mac like thank
you all right so if you guys are
interested in that you guys can look up
but sniffing pugs and check it out it's
pretty cute thank you guys for watching
see ya
Oh